and I don't sit around just talking to
experts because this is a college
seminar we talk to these folks because
they potentially had the best answers so
I know who's asked to kick if the
president is really serious about
kicking some ass over the BP oil spill
he should save some room for a swift
boot to his own derriere that's because
the federal government is a major player
in the disaster for at least three
reasons the leak which is dumped as much
as 30 million gallons of oil so far is
occurring in federally owned water in
Annecy bed that's leased from the
federal government while there's no
doubt that BP is chiefly responsible not
just for creating the mess but for
cleaning it up there's also no question
that the feds have a major role to play
the federal government regulates
offshore drilling the Minerals
Management Service which is part of the
Department of the Interior and is
charged with overseeing offshore
drilling has long been recognized as a
failed agency part of that is it's very
mission it's supposed to simultaneously
regulate the oil industry and maximize
royalty revenue from the lands at
controls no wonder MMS behavior has been
called scandalous and reprehensible by
Interior Secretary Ken Salazar the
federal government capped economic
damages for this kind of accident BP is
responsible for all the costs associated
with cleaning up the mess it caused but
the economic costs associated with the
spill all the damages to the oil fishing
tourism and other Gulf industries are
estimated at 15 billion dollars yet due
to legislation designed to keep smaller
industry players in the drilling game
bp's liability is capped at a measly 75
million dollars if drilling companies
knew that they would pay the full cost
of damages they would engage in less
risky behavior offshore drilling will
resume soon it's a risky practice but
that can be managed especially if the
government allows markets to price the
risks accurately and performs its
oversight role respond
that may not require a presidential
ass-kicking but it does mean changing
the way the government works for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie